you saw what happened with china right
china declares all cryptocurrency
transactions illegal you saw bitcoin
took a hit ethereum took a hit everybody
took a hit
uh with that so uh china central bank
has announced that all transactions of
cryptocurrencies are illegal effectively
banning digital tokens such as bitcoin
fluctuations there
often impact the global price of
cryptocurrencies and the price of
bitcoin fell by more than two thousand
dollars in a week of chinese
announcements it is the latest in
china's national crackdown on what is
what it sees as a volatile speculative
investment at best and a way to launder
money at worst trading
cryptocurrencies has officially been
banned in china since 2019 but has
continued online foreign exchanges but
last week's announcement is the clearest
indication yet that china wants to shut
down cryptocurrencies trading
in all its forms is what they want to do
so
freedom barry is um
barry's not a death you know he's got a
track record and people thought he was
crazy when he said that the housing
market was gonna crash i think when you
have that much credibility and you just
look at the evidence when you look at
inflation you look at the situation in
china with evergrande the debt ceiling
inflation global shipping shortage i
mean there's just so many things that
are stacked up against the stock market
continuing to boom
and china at the same time they're
showing their cards they're also kind of
telling the world look you know here's
the direction we're going if you there
was a girl that was a star social media
star with like 40 50 million followers
overnight she disappeared like what the
hell happened to her like a huge star
the guy that was worth 38 billion
dollars overnight his 38 billion dollars
is gone jack ma says one thing in front
of uh
you know talking against china hey
when's the last time you saw jack ma
doing an interview with cnbc or msnbc or
anything that was a year ago and that
was a year ago you talked about on rogan
about capitalism and communism and about
lifting up individuals but also like the
team the collective and that's kind of
what china's doing is they don't want
superstars they don't want superstars
yeah and this is shining a spotlight on
basically what china wants they want to
um they want control they want to you
know have regulation all over crypto but
something that we're not talking about
is because they're banning crypto and
banning bitcoin
part of the reason is they want to
develop their own digital wand and and
do all that so they
they you know we talked about the social
score on rogan you talked about that
china is basically trying to control
your whole life and they don't want
superstars that's why the people like
jack ma
you know yeah they go to re-education
camps well we we talked about it on the
last podcast guys that um you know
where's the epicenter of power in
america it used to be new york he used
to be dc maybe la it's it's all san
francisco now all tech right we talked
about it and he's betting against
america not once twice he's saying
treasury bonds are going down that's
betting against america you're betting
the country is is about to be in big bad
shape but you're betting on facebook and
google so if america is going down but
tech is going up i think that that kind
of tells you where where the power
within tech really lies and we we talk
not to get too crazy with it guys but i
mean if anybody out there wants to spend
the rest of their day going down a fun
rabbit hole check out the frankfurt
school check out what critical theory is
we hear a lot about critical race theory
today critical race theory is the latest
incarnation of something called critical
theory critical theory was a way that
hegelians and marxists decided that they
would try to implement communism in
society and basically you have to break
the wheel in order in order to implement
a communist revolution all right
worldwide communist revolution now i'm
not saying this is what's happening i'm
just saying if you want to do some fun
reading okay antonio gramsci who the
president of ireland just stopped and
paid respects to at his grave on the way
this is not a good man here
you know antonio graham not not a good
man i don't know what kind of a man he
was his philosophy is very dangerous so
in order to bring in a global communist
revolution you have to break the wheel
all right in times of prosperity nobody
wants revolution so in order for them if
you believe in in build back better if
you believe in a future where you will
own nothing and be happy
uh in order for that to happen a crash
is is is absolutely necessary and they
talk about it at length at the frankfurt
school to talk about cultural hegemony
this is guys if you've studied kind of
you know political theory if you if
you've studied this stuff a lot of this
is like you're seeing a slow-motion
train wreck
it's it's kind of nuts but just enjoy
check out the frankfurt school i think
you guys will get some value and some
payment out of that even if there is
this crash
that there's a crash so how many crashes
have we experienced time
so
let's say 10.
boom i'm saying in the last 20 years.com
boom lasted a year or so 2008 lasted a
couple years
20 i mean covet lasted like six months
as far as the the market goes
so
it's gonna crash it's a crash the
housing crash the market crash
if you're young and you're in the stock
market you have crypto is are you really
that worried there's one thing more
older people did i tell you one thing
concerns me here's what concerns me i
agree you know how it's like
it's cyclical it happens it's cyclical
it happens this is no different it's
cyclical it happens this is no different
it's cyclical it happens right okay fine
let's say it is only cyclical and it
happens there's one thing that's not
normal
um
40 plus percent of the currency was
printed last 18 months right that's a
lot of money was sent free to people bro
we've not sent like money like that to
people we're just people are sitting on
the sidelines saying no if you pay me
this i'll come and companies like
this guy's only worth
18 bucks an hour at best i have to pay
this guy 28 bucks to come back to work
what the hell do i do okay i'll give you
28 bucks and okay and you better not let
me go out 458 and then it's like a very
weird dynamic that's going on today
right like
employers are begging and this is what
they want employers are begging people
to come back to work and people say no
i'm good man i'm playing video games i'm
chilling playing netflix so how long
when that goes do you get the person
want to come back and really give their
best i don't know so that's one thing
that leads to fake success now they're
talking another three and a half
trillion dollars
which i don't know if you've looked at
what's in the three and a half trillion
dollars again a bunch of other
that they've added to the three and a
half three and a half trillion dollars
well the senate just struck it down and
you saw what biden just said you know
what biden just said with the money when
no americans are not going to pay for it
this is not going to go to the death
effort
this is not going to go to our deficit
will not pay anything for it it's going
to pay for itself pelosi is saying it's
going to pay for itself it's going to
pay for its sales job right and you know
what she said again here's what she said
look let's just pass it so we can find
out what's in it same line she's used
in the past before
this is not a new thing that these guys
are doing so are you saying that and i
gave you three examples 2001 2008 2020
that this potential crash would be worse
go to each one go to each one yeah what
is a one oh one was just you know
dot com boom box
oh one what you're talking about nine
eleven talking about no well it was 99
yeah 99 2000 2001 all that free money
yeah private equity got into the game
okay and they started putting money to
people that really didn't have the best
idea and it was just like it flapped
just as long as that calm behind it and
then
that was the market and then obviously
911. so it was a lot of fake money there
but it was created by who
the market created fake money okay in
98.99 the more we're evaluating
companies that's right the market so
that's cool if the market creates fake
success guess what you're going to take
you're going to lose billions and you're
going to have to come back and treat it
in different ways that's the correction
go to osa that's a correction go to o7
what was what was the deal with 07.
housing housing a program comes from
australia called no income no ass it's
nina okay where it's a pick a payment
and everybody's buying a million dollar
house michael murray everything that's
right and the big short and then what
happens there fake success
more fake success so who takes a hit a
330 billion dollar company called wamu
gets bought by a chase for 1.9 billion
dollars
there were some victims bear stearns had
to go down sure um but who else okay
well that's a lot about there's a lot a
lot of victims i mean country-wide you
forget countrywide was like all over the
place fremont invested it's a little big
mortgage so but then you go to today
so you said 0-1 right 08 today today
what was today 2020 exactly well 2020 is
a co kobe because if kobe doesn't hit
trump's getting re-elected the economy
was doing great people were working
people were talking just talked about
the median income had increased for the
first time in 20 years it had increased
to 60 000 from 55 000 under his watch
unemployment for everybody was fine
record low blacks hispanics women in
every way everything was good china was
having to kind of change back and kind
of see what they're going to do with u.s
you know isis you didn't hear a single
thing about isis all that stuff sweets
pat but but but i will tell you though
there's a part of that that he he is his
own enemy there's there's nobody that's
a bigger enemy than himself on what he
did but his his policies very effective
policies then covet shows up and kobe
becomes a great opportunity to do what
impose any ideas that you want we could
have been united and the enemy would
have been china but no instead of
creating the enemy because like right
now let's just say uh uh let's just say
something happens in this building okay
and the building uh uh is on fire okay
when a building's on fire there's a
couple things the building could do like
remember that one day the car was on
fire everybody's running i'm on a board
call they're telling me pat you got to
go downstairs all this other stuff i
don't remember this it was like four
weeks ago yeah okay told me not to come
in that day
so guess what happened wait they tell
you not to come in every day
watch what happens that day
what happened that day when they told us
it's a fire do you actually remember no
we're going oh you weren't here so we
ran downstairs we're holding doors for
each other come on folks let's go come
on let's go too because the enemy was
what the fire right makes sense now
imagine if somebody said
he did it it's his fault this guy did it
he's doing it it's because of him and
we're like who him hi it's good
so so the point is
rather than using covet to unify america
the left saw this and say perfect
opportunity to make trump the villain
ding ding ding ding ding you win he's
out but the reality was china caused the
great divorce
china is the one that caused the fire
that's the challenge that we have and
now fast forward to today you give all
this money to people for a while and you
get employers to go against employ
everything right now is against against
employers against employees
men against women parents against kids
okay republicans against democrats
police
versus
that constant against is what's causing
us to be yeah and it's becoming the new
normal which is what's which is what
they want and which is really really so
this is a very different thing so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]